il y avait encore une fois différentes
sources pour cette info sur la frappe de
l'hôpital il y avait un communiqué qui
vient de la partie militaire de Hamas
qu'on a pas touché qui a parlé de de 500
morts euh il y a une communiqué qui
vient de système hospitalier qui qui a
parlé de je pense quelques centaines
morts qu'on a
repris
sorcé c'était c'était comme on fait
assez souvent avec une allégation
c'était clairement sorcé à à
l'administration médicale sous contrôle
de
Hamas
alors est-ce qu'on aura le luxe de ne
pas traiter cette info non parce que ça
partte c'est c'est c'est c'est sur
toutes les chaînes en boucle arabe c'est
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est notre
boulot d'y aller et de contextualiser et
et et et de faire notre boulot de de
vérification et
contextualisation on aurait dû être plus
prudent dans la manière dont on a on a
écrit La Dépêche on aurait dû être plus
ferme euh sur le fait que AFP était pas
sur place que AFP était pas en mesure de
confirmer l'allégation de de Hamas parce
que c'était une allégation qui était
très gros à la formulation des mots euh
était pas parfait on a changé nos
consignes après euh pour juste changer
la manière dont on formule euh certaines
choses quand on parle de de ramas euh et
après la complexité c'était
euh l'attente pour pour vraiment la
partie israélienne on a eu une réaction
assez rapide des israliennes qui dis on
est en train de de regarder mais ça a
pris 3 He pour avoir le contenarratif et
3 He dans le temps réel et c'est toute
la complexité du travail de la FP c'est
le travail de temps réel 3h dans le
temps réel c'est c'est énorme c'est
énorme mais bien sûr dès qu'on a eu la
réaction israélienne on on a alerté on a
on a complètement changé la manière
d'écrire les dépêches on a on a on a
fait
tout mais c'est ce 3 heur qui qui qui
qui est
compliqué et c'est quelque chose que
j'ai discuté avec mes mes mes
homologues et et il y a pas une solution
très simple à ça parce que c'est c'est
le contexte dans lequel on travaille le
contexte des réseaux le contexte de de
de de voilà de l'information qu' qu'on
maîtrise pas c'est pas les agences
maintenant qui maîtrise la diffusion de
l'info l'info parte immédiatement sur
les réseaux et après on chasse après
pour
contextualiser c'était pas fa possible
d'y aller immédiatement c'était
extrêmement dangereux c'était toute la
zone où l'armée israélienne a dit c'est
exclu d'être là si vous êtes là vous
êtes une
cible ça veut dire que c'était pas
possible juste d'y aller immédiatement
et regarder ce que se passe on est allé
le jour après et même là c'était
dangereux il y avait déjà des des
frappes autour de nos équipes é moi
j'étais pas à l'aise avec le fait qu'on
y allit mais ils sont très courageux ils
sont allés là-bas vraiment pour pour
filmer pour interviever pour essayer de
comprendre et on a travaillé sur une
grosse enquête sur sur sur ces questions
là pour essayer de comprendre avec
vraiment des des
témoignages l'équipe qui travaille sur
les réseaux on on a fait une grosse
enquête pour pour comprendre ce que
s'est passé mais mais mais il faut
comprendre que c'est extrêmement
difficile de de faire les chos qu'on
veut faire le plus c'est de témoigner
nous-même sur des choses qui se passent
parce que il y a toujours cette menace
notamment dans dans le nord de Gaza à
Gaza City